oh folks uh
you know you don't have to stand every
time i hear hail of the chief wonder
where the hell is he
it took me a long while you think i'm
joking i'm not
turning around where where's where's the
president
[Music]
is this the reuben report who who's the
host of that show they say dave ruben
where the hell is he where is he who
hi everybody i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report it is july 13th 2022. uh
we are live streaming on rumble youtube
and blaze tv uh do me a favor and
subscribe if you have not particularly
on rumble or over on blaze who knows
what's gonna happen with youtube you
know we live in crazy times uh first off
i have to tell you guys i am a man of my
word i did take the team to the miami
marlins
game last night uh not everyone had
chicken fingers that was the big debate
as we walked in
connor and i had chicken fingers michael
and phoenix had hot dogs and then wait a
minute then you got chicken fingers too
phoenix was very hungry he had hot dogs
and chicken fingers so that's an
important update for you people also uh
it was just announced before the show
that inflation has hit 9.1 percent so
your chicken fingers and your hot dogs
are going to be more expensive going
forward good thing we went last night
guys because next time it's one box of
cracker jacks for everybody that's it
that's it anyway we got a big show for
you today uh yesterday was our biggest
show ever our most clips our longest
show ever and if i dare say so myself it
was pretty solid uh but today we are
going to dive back into the insanity
because yesterday we were it was a
little sort of off-route situation we
did uh some of the this globalist stuff
and this world economic forum stuff and
this klaus schwab stuff scary dude uh
but today we're heading back here to the
united states because the craziness
continues there was uh maybe you've seen
some clips of this already but we got a
whole bunch for you there was a
completely
completely
bananas should be studied senate
judiciary committee hearing yesterday on
uh the roe v wade verdict and this is
where the senators get up there and they
ask experts of their feelings about you
know what happened in in this
specific reversal of roe v wade and uh
there was a
uc berkeley law professor by the name of
chiara bridges who was questioned by a
couple senators and it was just nuts but
it's a perfect example of the radicalism
that we are seeing everywhere that there
is just right now
we have one party in the country
that is deeply radical that is trying to
destroy all the norms that is not proud
of this country that does not know basic
math or basic biology or anything else
and then we got another party that is
not so great but certainly better than
that thing uh so that will be the theme
of the show today uh real quick guys uh
at 5 00 pm today if you're on the
instagram i'm doing an instagram live
with fox news contributor lisa booth who
will be joining me tomorrow night in
miami uh there are a couple seats left
at the miami improv i will be there with
christina pusha lisa booth my buddy dave
raboy we're going to do a live episode
of the reuben report all with clips from
today and tomorrow we're going to write
the show just a few minutes before pull
it all together for you we'll do a live
q a and all that good stuff dave
rubin.com events i think there's about
10 tickets left real quick let's talk
about jen yourself and then let's get to
it you know do you ever look in the
mirror and notice dark sunspots on your
face it can certainly be a concern for
me since i'm now an official resident of
hot and sunny florida well i've got some
good news for you jenyasel's new product
line is amazing samantha from arcadia
writes love geniusel plant stem cell
therapy have used it all over my face
under my eyes and it cleared up the dry
flakiness and even reduced my forehead
lines someone even asked if i had
surgery or procedures done nope just
geniusel by shamany there she is raving
about her transformative results janucel
has sold over a million products to
women and men across this country of
ours and everyone falls in love with the
results fine lines forehead wrinkles
dark spots and even those annoying bags
and puffiness gone right before your
eyes best of all januselle guarantees
results in as little as 12 hours or your
money back
now see the difference yourself with 65
percent off their most popular packages
at januselle.com that's 65 off all
customer favorites including the classic
under eye bag and puffiness treatment
visit januselle.com dave and enter code
dave at checkout for 20 off uh that's
jen yourself g-e-n-u-c-e-l
dot com slash dave jennycell.com dave
and now back to me here we go all right
so there was this really just nutty i
mean it's just nutty but it's nutty in
the way that everything's nutty right
you wake up every morning and you go
okay what's going to be nutty today boys
are girls girls are boys 2 plus 2 is 5
blah blah blah nothing makes sense we
don't know anything that we knew that
was obvious two years ago so they had
this big senate hearing yesterday
to review
the
reversal of roe v wade and a whole bunch
of senators were up there senators on
both sides of the aisle by the way and
they get to call out
they get to call on experts law
professors scientists etc to share their
opinions on this reversal of roe v wade
so one of the people that was called
upon was a uc berkeley law professor by
the name of kiara bridges and she
was questioned
by senator josh hawley from missouri
professor bridges you said several times
you've used a phrase i want to make sure
i understand what you mean by it you've
referred to people with a capacity for
pregnancy
would that be women
many women cis women have the capacity
for pregnancy many cis women do not have
the capacity for pregnancy um there are
also trans men who are capable of
pregnancy as well as non-binary people
who are capable of pregnancy so this
isn't really a women's rights issue it's
uh we can recognize that this impacts
women while also recognizing that it
impacts other groups those things are
not mutually exclusive senator hawley oh
so your view is is that the core of this
this right then is about what
so um i want to recognize that your line
of questioning um is transphobic
and it opens up trans people to violence
by not recognizing that wow you're
saying that i'm opening up people to
violence by asking whether or not women
are the folks who can have pregnancies
because denying that trans people exist
and pretending not to know that they
exist i'm denying that trans people
exist by asking are you if you're
talking are you about women are you
having pregnancies do you believe that
the uh men can get pregnant
no i don't think so so you're saying
that trans people like this thing and
that leads to violence is this how you
run your classroom are students allowed
to question you or are they also treated
like this
they're opening up people to violence we
have a good time in my class you should
join my best you might learn a lot wow
this is what's going on in our
government and our halls of higher
education okay so let's do the obvious
part first you guys can see this woman
who again is a uc
berkeley professor now uc berkeley used
to be an actual place of higher
education berkeley in the 60s and 70s
was the home it really was the
educational home of the free speech
movement in america when liberals used
to care about free speech believe it or
not they did a long time ago check out
the aclu back in the 60s and 70s i know
it's a far cry from what it is today
but she is a professor at uc berkeley
which is now a hotbed of woke
progressive radical leftism insanity all
he basically is saying there is the
obvious thing we know that it's women
who get pregnant everyone knows it it is
women who get pregnant dudes cannot get
pregnant the idea that i even have to
say that that you even have to watch
something to hear that that the
government has to spend time on this
that there are professors teaching these
things
shows you how
how they've dragged us they've just
dragged us to this endless abyss that
woman is not a defender of women
she's a defender of craziness of of some
sort of real bizarro nonsense like she's
a defender of a political ideology more
than women all he's saying is hey is it
just women that can get pregnant and we
all know that we all know that okay i
can't get pregnant i cannot get pregnant
you can you get pregnant that dude can't
get pregnant you can you get pregnant he
wasn't sure you okay yes he said yes all
right well i'm gonna have to talk to you
the point is guys can't get pregnant
i've enjoyed my time on youtube but
there i said it it's all so stupid and
then of course what she says is if you
even question my insane
logic on this you are transphobic now
let's just talk about the word phobic
for a second because a phobia is an
irrational fear an irrational fear to
question this professor's feelings on
gender ideology means that josh hawley
has an irrational fear of trans people
meaning if there was a trans person
walking down the street and by the way
sometimes a trans person's walking down
the street you don't know that he would
have an irrational fear and he would run
the other way now of course that's
nonsense and of course it's also
nonsense that that is causing violence
by the way i'll even go a step further
if josh hawley who's been on this show
if josh hawley was pushing for some sort
of law in missouri that was going to
criminalize
people being trans meaning once you're
an adult and able to make medical
decisions for yourself and live as you
wish if he was criminalizing that in any
way if he was ensuring that these people
couldn't get jobs or couldn't get proper
medical attention or anything like that
i would be 100 without equivocation
against josh hawley and that bill i
believe in equal rights for everybody
but equality
doesn't guarantee doesn't isn't
automatically connected to you having to
be an idiot and that is what these
people seemingly have connected
everything to so josh hawley is a
transphobe he is causing violence
against against these people and again
who is more into science is it this
professor who teaches this stuff or is
it the guy who's like yeah i think girls
can get pregnant and i don't think boys
can
which one is it well it continued chiara
continued here she is clashing with
senator john cornyn
about human life and the origins of
human life senator john cornyn from
texas of course do you think a
baby that is delivered alive
has value
yes
do you think that a
a baby that is not yet born
has value i believe that a person with a
capacity for pregnancy has value they
have intelligence they have agency i'm
talking about the baby and i'm talking
about the person with the capacity
you're not answering the question i'm
asking i mean i'm answering it more
interesting you think that you think
that the baby that is not yet born
let's say the day before this mother
delivers do you think that baby has
value i think that the person with the
capacity for pregnancy has value and
they have the they should have the
ability to control what happens to their
lives well
man i don't know what to call these
people other than a death call they
really are now first off uh the fact
that she calls a woman and it is only
women who can give birth it's only women
with uteruses and eggs and all of that
stuff vaginas and all that um
i'm blowing minds today i really am
um the fact that she calls them
a person with the capacity
for pregnancy
and this she this woman i have no doubt
calls herself a feminist right she's a
feminist she is a modern feminist she is
for the female except she probably
doesn't know what a female is because
she's not a biologist and when she
refers to women she refers to them in
the most sort of psychotically
clinical terms a person with the
capacity for pregnancy but what's really
more perverse and why this really is a
death cult and i say this
as someone
that's still after all of this nonsense
and all of the craziness of the last
couple years i still consider myself
begrudgingly pro-choice you guys know my
feelings on this hopefully you've read
my books i do not deny when the egg
meets the sperm that is the moment of
life that that moment of conception is
the beginning of everything but i
fundamentally believe there's a
difference between splitting of cells
over a series of time
before you have uh functioning organs
and all of those things but we can all
get into our own philosophical beliefs
on this and our own religious beliefs on
this and how you balance all of those
things betw with living in a purely
secular society and states rights and
all that okay i know you guys get all
that but what they can no longer do
these radical
woke progressive crazy people what they
can no longer do is say anything honest
she knows she knows that an eight month
eight month fetus
of course is a living human being we
know that at 24 weeks babies can now
live outside of the womb so i think it's
happened even a little bit before that
um
the idea that at eight months this isn't
i right now right at this very moment i
have a surrogate who has an eight-month
baby i'm gonna be a dad in about a month
from now it's crazy
but there is a woman who has a child in
her that is obviously a living child
these people who are they're not for
women they're not for children they are
not for humans and they're not for logic
and reason and anything else but she
continued here she is going ballistic on
senator ted cruz from texas and mike lee
from utah
senator lee senator cruz have talked
about oh this decision just to turn
through this dobbs decision just
returned it to the
elected representatives of states too
and people can battle it out in these
laboratories of democracy as to whether
they want to protect fetal life over the
interest of of the pregnant person these
are the same states that are stopping
people from voting texas has the most
restrictive voting laws on the books
texas sba doesn't represent the will of
the majority of texans texas sba
represents the will of the majority of
texans that were able to vote so in
order for this to be a democracy we have
to protect voting rights and i i leave
it to
everyone in this in this room as well as
the rest of congress to prevent voting
rights so that we can be a real
democracy
ah now you see what it's all about and
this is what intersectionality is all
about this is what wokism is all about
and modern progressivism is all about
it's combining a jillion issues that
have nothing to do with each other
in such a way that you can actually
topple democracy so that you can topple
our system and fight it from the inside
that's what this is really about because
first off the dobbs decision whether you
are a hundred percent pro-choice
or a hundred percent pro-life the dobbs
decision did exactly what she described
right there which is what ted cruz and
mike lee were saying all it did was kick
it back to the states and then yes you
get this this laboratory of democracy
this ongoing experiment where people on
the ground can make decisions about
their lives and if they don't like it in
one place they can go somewhere else or
if they do like it elsewhere they can go
there i mean this is a beautiful thing
this is a beautiful precious thing that
we have here that most countries don't
have that most people in other places in
the world would love to have because if
you live in most other western
democracies you have a government that
basically runs the whole show but here
although we we often give too much power
to the to the federal government we have
a system of states rights so things are
extremely different depending on where
you live i used to live in california an
evil dystopian place with high taxes and
crime and drugs everywhere now i live in
the free state of florida it's very very
different and feels like living in a
different country okay so she says that
but then of course she links this to
voting rights and that's what they do
because they're only in this for the
destruction of everything there is no
buddy in texas that is a legal citizen
of texas that cannot vote when she talks
about restrictive voting rights in texas
she's saying things like ids but why
does it why is it that a certain set of
people don't want voter id why do
progressives not want voter id because
they want to cheat it's the only answer
it is the only answer when i lived in
cali i did not have to show an id to
vote i literally had to say my name and
my address i could have walked into the
same polling place the very next day
with another pollster there and i know
my neighbor's name and i know my
neighbor's address and i could have
voted as my neighbor that's what they
want there why would they want that do
you think they might want to screw
around with the ballots why is it in
california
when you have a mail-in ballot as we had
during the recall for gavin newsom that
no matter which way you folded the
envelope and i tried this even though i
voted in person because they also send
you the mail and no matter which way you
folded the envelope you could either see
yes or no on recall on one side or larry
elder's name on the other just by taking
the envelope and holding it up to basic
light basic sunlight right you didn't
even have to use an iphone camera or an
iphone flashlight for it they want this
craziness there is nobody again nobody
nobody and that's why she can't
reference anything these restrictive
voting rights uh these restrictive
voting bills in texas they're stopping
people no they're not they're not
stopping anyone from voting when you
when you what you guys mean by
restrictive is legal meaning that there
should be some paper trail we should pay
attention to who's voting make sure that
you are who you say you are but she
somehow is combining this into
transphobia and the patriarchy and all
of these things because that's all these
people got they got a bunch of crazy
stuff but if you think that is crazy if
you think hearing that woman
is nuts
i'm gonna show you uh mazzy hirono first
in a moment this was the woman she is
the senator from hawaii and she is just
insane and we're going to destroy you
know we're going to destroy mazzy hirono
today you guys want to destroy mazzy
hirono we're going to destroy mazzie
hirono but first guys real quick let me
talk about liquid iv i love liquid iv
and i had some this morning because i
ate the chicken fingers i had a beer and
a margarita at the game last night and
you know in the hot summer months here
in florida you need to be proactive
about your body and stay hydrated making
hydration a priority can help us feel
healthier in our everyday lives one
stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water hydrates you two times faster and
more efficiently than water alone plus
liquid iv tastes great with 10
refreshing flavors like concord grape
lemon lime pina colada and tropical
punch sounds like summer doesn't it i
used liquid iv last night after coming
back from the game as i just said and i
feel good and i'm sharp today wouldn't
you guys say i'm sharp
very sharp today pina colada is my
favorite personally but you guys can
have whatever you want grab your liquid
iv uh in bulk nationwide at costco or
you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use code rubin at
checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you shop for better hydration
today using promo code
rubenliquidiv.com and now back to me all
right let's destroy let's play let's
destroy
hawaii senator mazzy hirono here's mazzy
at this hearing yesterday and she
doesn't know what the founders thought
she doesn't know why she has a job she
doesn't even know what she's doing in
that room originalism they have the
justices who take that approach go all
the way back to
our founding fathers and pretend that
they know what our founding fathers
meant
when they drafted the constitution
i use the word pretend because who the
heck what should what would know
what our founding fathers meant is there
any reference to ar-15 rifles in our
constitution
this is actually one of the most
extraordinary things i think that has
ever been said by a sitting senator in
any one of these hearings or in any
cable news interview or anywhere else
that we should have no idea what the
founding fathers meant how would we know
that stuff was written hundreds of years
ago those guys had white wigs on their
head and wore funny socks how would we
have any sense what these people were
doing we're very advanced now with our
tweeter machine and all of those things
well mazzy hirono i'm going to destroy
you right now because we did our
research and we found some writings from
these old people with their white wigs
and their funny socks and i thought i
would read to you some of the things
that they said
way back when because they were pretty
well thought out and they did an awful
lot of research and they seriously
thought of the not only of the issues of
the day but how
issues over generations and over long
periods of time would often reoccur and
how we could best protect the
individual's right to live freely so
here we got a little something mazzy i
don't know if you've heard of this thing
there's something called the
constitution
it's the founding document of the united
states and i thought i'd read you a
little bit of the preamble of the
constitution and maybe we can figure out
what these old white guys in white wigs
and funny socks and some of them a
little partly uh due to the the diet at
the time uh what they were thinking
because she has no idea what these
people were thinking here we go preamble
of the constitution we the people of the
united states in order to form a more
perfect union establish justice
ensure domestic tranquility
provide for the common defense
promote the general welfare and secure
the blessings of liberty to ourselves
and our posterity do ordain and
establish this constitution for the
united states of america oh boy that
that seems pretty straightforward mazzy
i mean they were basically writing
documents to make sure
people could live
freely and they were pretty clean and
clear about what they were saying well
then we had this other thing it was this
declaration it was a very specific thing
that it was declaring it was declaring
our independence we even called it the
declaration of independence and they
wrote some pretty thoughtful stuff in
there too mazzy here we go
sometimes it becomes necessary for a
group of people to declare their
independence from a government they used
to be connected to they have a right to
do so under natural law though they
should respectfully lay out the reasons
for the separation
it is obvious that all people have the
right to equal treatment and that god
gives people rights to life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness that can
neither be taken nor given away
the only legitimate purpose of
government is make sure that these
individual rights are protected and the
only legitimate way for such governments
to exist is for the people to consent to
their existence
but if a government ever fails in its
task to protect individual rights the
people have the right to alter or
abolish it and create a new government
based on whatever principles they
think best boy so they do seem pretty
clear it does seem like these people
have thought this stuff through they
want to protect individual rights they
want to make sure that the government
can't come for those rights and they
want to make sure that you have a
recourse in case the government does
that but mazzy has just no idea what
these people were doing again she's just
she is so clueless she maybe never read
a book never went to school so i thought
well we'll continue with this education
of mazzy hirono we also added amendments
to these documents rather extraordinary
because we wanted to really really
enshrine and ensure that these rights
would not be taken away we have
something called the bill of rights uh
here's the first amendment i don't know
if mazzy's heard of this one i mean she
just doesn't know what these people were
thinking congress shall make no law
representing an establishment of
religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof or abridging the
freedom of speech or of the press or of
the right of the people to peaceably
assemble and to petition the government
for a redress of grievances then there's
also the second amendment i don't know
if mazzy's heard of this one a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed now those
were of course in the bill of rights the
original bill of rights those are two of
the first 10 and then later on the
states added some more here's the 13th
neither slavery nor involuntary
servitude except as a punishment for
crime whereof the party shall have been
duly convicted shall exist within the
united states or any place subject to
their jurisdiction and we've got one
more for you the 14th amendment
all persons born or naturalized in the
united states and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof are citizens of the
united states and of the state wherein
they reside no state shall make or
enforce any law which shall abridge the
privileges or immunities of citizens of
the united states nor shall any state
deprive any person of life liberty or
property without due process of law nor
deny any person within its jurisdiction
the equal protection of the laws okay so
mazzy hirono this is your life you
became a senator in the greatest country
in the history of the world which was
founded by extraordinary people who are
far better than you and far better than
me who thought through as many of the
issues as humans have ever been able to
think so that we could have a country
250 years later that has brought more
freedom onto the world than would have
ever been imaginable but you just don't
know what those people think now what
she's also doing there very specifically
and she even said the word she's
attacking originalism okay now
originalism is the concept that we
should always go back to exactly what
the documents say right that you don't
want to change the meaning of the
documents over time because if you keep
doing that then over time the documents
will actually mean nothing so she's
really against the idea of originalism
and most of the left and democrats and
liberal judges are against originalism
they often want to change the documents
to fit the moments of today so we
thought we'd dive into originalism a
little bit uh 60 minutes did an
interview with antonin scalia a couple
years back discussing why he
is a constitutional originalist tonight
from 10 years ago when we interviewed
the late supreme court justice antonin
scalia he was a polarizing figure with a
sharp wit and piercing intellect
he was a constitutional originalist a
philosophy he laid out for us
it's what what did the words mean to the
people who ratified the bill of rights
or who ratified the constitution as
opposed to what people today think as
opposed to what people today would like
but you do admit that values change
we do
adapt we move fine and so do laws change
because values change
legislatures abolish the death penalty
permit same-sex marriage if they want
abolish laws against homosexual conduct
that's how the change in a society
occurs
and that's how it's supposed to occur
that you look at what's in those
founding documents and we are governed
by what's in those things but then we
have something called the legislative
process
and each state has its own
legislature and each state can then make
laws within that state and then
eventually if they make a law that goes
against the constitution that might work
its way all the way up to the supreme
court the supreme court might strike
that down
but as he said right there we have
expanded rights through legislatures so
you can still be an originalist and say
hey what's on this paper this actually
matters these are the guidelines and
then if you want to do other things you
go to the states to do it now of course
anton and scalia has since passed away
and he was hated by much of the
mainstream media and he was hated by
pretty much everybody on the left uh
there's a new guy that they hate right
now they really really hate him you may
remember what laurie lightfoot said
about justice clarence thomas just uh
what was that about two weeks ago it
involved the f word yeah you remember
that
and that he's a house blah blah blah and
all of those things well he shares that
exact same philosophy of originalism uh
here is uh justice clarence thomas
responding to some of his critics
steve croft to 60 minutes asked thomas
about why he's still so quiet
the perception is where the critics will
say it's because
you're not smart enough or you're you're
too insecure or you're afraid of making
a fool out of yourself well they make
fools out of themselves with those kind
of comments
justice marshall rarely asks questions
justice powell rarely asks questions
that's a personal preference i certainly
wouldn't do it to provide histrionics
for on the media gallery or for other
people or for critics critics will
always be critics
critics will always be critics and the
critics are always going after this guy
you can see in that interview they're
saying oh you don't you don't say much
you you write your briefs right you
write your commentary after the
decisions people can understand your
thinking very clearly but you don't say
much i love the word histrionics like i
love the fact that he's like i'm not a
pontificator i'm not someone who just
gets up there to talk just for the sake
of talking and get the media attention
and all of that uh but this is so
consistent the left went from hating
antonin scalia now they hate clarence
thomas even though they tell you that
they're for
all black people but of course what they
mean by that is just black people who
behave and speaking of people who only
like black people who behave
back in 1991 when justice clarence
thomas or 2b justice clarence thomas was
going through his hearings as to whether
he was going to be confirmed or not
there was a guy by the name of joe biden
and joe biden basically led the democrat
charge to get rid of clarence thomas
make sure that he would not be a supreme
court justin it was very famously called
a political lynching uh biden basically
invented this this is this is really
when where now everything is so
politicized these hearings are so
politicized before this it was not if
you'd gotten if the president nominated
somebody they pretty much just went
through it was joe biden it really was
joe biden and the dems who switched uh
this whole situation and and created it
it's called borking because it started
when uh when joe biden attacked robert
fork who eventually did not get
confirmed uh but here's a little bit
more of thomas's response uh to joe
biden of the dems way back when you
denied all of the allegations oh
absolutely from day one it didn't happen
i mean so if somebody makes a broad
allegation against you
what would you do
ask him to prove it i guess
yeah when it came time for him to
publicly respond to the allegations
thomas turned the tables on his
interrogators and for all intents and
purposes ended the debate this is a
circus it's a national disgrace
it is a high-tech lynching for uppity
blacks
who in any way deign to think for
themselves
and it is a message
that unless you kowtow to an old order
you will be lynched
destroyed
caricatured
by a committee of the u.s u.s senate
rather than hung from a tree
why did you use that language i mean why
a high-tech lynching
if somebody just wantedly tries to
destroy you somebody comes in and just
drags you out of your house and beats
the hell out of you what is it
what do you want people to think about
those allegations what's what is it
important really at this point i think
most well-meaning people understand it
for what it was
it was a weapon to destroy me
clear and simple
i always say it guys but when you hear
the truth when you hear someone that
honestly is saying what they believe man
is it refreshing and
you look at that video from 1991 and
that shot where the camera goes to biden
as he's basically saying you you led the
charge on destroying me well it's like
clarence thomas is still here clarence
thomas is still cognizant and cogent and
doing a fine job and that is certainly
far more than joe biden is doing right
now
but you know this is all sort of
unfolding in real time the craziness is
unfolding in real time and it's not just
that they're sending these crazy
berkeley professors to uh testify that
men are women and that eight month
fetuses are not life and all that
it's that their politicians are
completely insane you guys know uh
socialist multi-millionaire elizabeth
warren senator fake native american
senator from massachusetts well we
played a video last week of her going
nuts i mean really just going nuts
hysteria in her eyes uh that there are
too many crisis pregnancy centers now
crisis pregnancy centers in contrast to
abortion clinics are places where women
who are struggling with their pregnancy
maybe they don't have financial means
maybe their parents aren't happy maybe
they are with an abusive boyfriend
whatever their issue is related to being
pregnant they go there and then there is
a series these are non-profit
organizations there are a series of ways
that they can help them either
financially or medically or
psychologically et cetera et cetera so
that they don't have to abort the child
this is you would think regardless of
what side of the abortion thing you're
on you'd go oh this is actually pretty
good so maybe we could help these women
they could have the baby either keep the
baby or leave it for adoption etc you
would think this is a good thing but
elizabeth warren who last week went
absolutely crazy because there's too
many of these things well she's
continuing she just wants to kill poor
people's babies
in massachusetts right now
those
crisis pregnancy centers
that are there
to fool people who are looking for
pregnancy termination help
outnumber
true abortion clinics by three to one
we need to shut them down here in
massachusetts and we need to shut them
down all around the country
you should not be able
to torture a pregnant person like that
i mean she is a sick [ __ ] i i don't know
how you can describe it in any other way
that somehow helping a woman have a baby
is torture helping a woman decide not to
have an abortion is fooling that woman
and then she wants to use the power of
the state the power of the government we
need to shut these places down lady
those aren't the places that are killing
the babies
those are the places trying to ensure
that a baby can be brought into this
world in a safe way to make sure that
that woman doesn't have to make this
horrible decision
she is absolutely insane but she's
exactly the perfect
the perfect progressive woke democrat
whether it is a professor at berkeley
who can't tell you what a man or a woman
is and wants to abort an eight-month
child or whether it is a socialist
multi-millionaire telling you and these
are poor people mostly who will go to
these pregnancy centers so what she is
saying is i want to ensure yes i am
super rich yes i send my kids to private
school while i push public school on
everybody else sure i don't know what a
man or a woman is all of that stuff
but i want to ensure that we don't trick
women we don't fool women we don't
torture poor often black and latino
women to actually have a baby because
that's the worst thing these are crazy
people they went the democrats went man
i tried i tried years ago remember why i
left the left hey libs are we doing
anything here they went from being the
party of safe legal and rare that used
to be the the standard democrat position
if the republican position was we are
pro-life we do not want abortion we want
to reverse roe v wade and kick it back
to the states the position of the sane
democrat which was a position that chuck
schumer used to hold that even nancy
pelosi used to hold and joe biden used
to hold and every sane democrat before
these last five years we are the party
of safe legal and rare abortion we don't
celebrate abortion we don't want
eight-month abortions let's have an
honest assessment of when an abortion
can be had or should be had or whatever
related to all of that uh that they've
gone from that to pregnancy pregnancy
centers are domestic terrorist
organizations that's basically where
they're at these people are crazy and
let's not forget that video that we
showed you just a couple days ago joe
biden in 1988 government should stay out
of it his actual quote was not for it
not against it
but it continues it continues with these
people it's not just that they don't
know what boys and girls are it's not
just that they want to kill as many poor
brown children as possible they also
want to pander to high hell so dr jill
biden who's a doctor of what we have no
idea but as i've been saying she clearly
hasn't examined her husband she gave a
talk at a latino or a latina or a la
tinx depending on what you like to say
organization two days ago and if this
isn't the most pandering nonsense you've
ever heard then i'd like to sell you
a burrito
but we can't get those things on our own
raul helped build this organization with
the understanding that the diversity of
this community
as distinct as the bogotas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san antonio
[Applause]
is your strength
the bodegas of the bronx the bodegas
lady the bodegas i lived in new york
city every corner out of bodega bodega
we don't know what that is and then of
course it's so diverse you you brown
people are so diverse when i see you
hondurans and you mexicans and you
people from guadalajara and wherever
else you're from i think of tacos and
you you're a carne asada and we got a
pork taco over there and a fish taco
these people they are such pandering
buffoons this is hillary clinton
remember hillary clinton when she was on
charlemagne the god right i can't keep
calling him back can i get his real name
i don't want to call him charlemagne the
god um
anyway he remember when she was running
for president and he was like what do
you always keep on you and she was like
hot sauce it's always in my pocketbook
and it's like what the flying
you people
are just absolutely terrible but i got
to tell you guys just totally joking
aside this morning i was starving this
morning i woke up i was just you know we
wake up sometimes you're just really
really hungry and i was like i'm going
to go downstairs and make myself a
delicious uh breakfast taco which i
often do and i go down there and i'm
eating this most delicious breakfast
taco and then i had this like moment i
was like
and i looked and it turned out i wasn't
eating a breakfast taco i was actually
chewing jose's hand jose is my mexican
gardener and he had come inside for some
water and i saw him and i thought he was
a and i was chewing on his hand and i
put hot sauce on it and everything was
nuts so jose i know you're a big fan of
the show and i'm watching and i
apologize and i'm so sorry anyway
uh i think we've got the warning for you
because the crazy ladies of the view
there you go what you're about to see
okay the crazy ladies of the view they
chimed in on dr jill biden's comments
and look i i honestly it's it's a stupid
thing that she said nobody look i don't
think well i think she is racist in a
way right because even because these
progressives they are racist because
they've whittled everyone down to skin
color and the pandering nonsense uh but
what the reason i'm showing you the view
right now let's put the warning up again
i want people to really feel the warning
um the reason that i'm showing you this
clip is that if ted cruz who happens to
be uh latino descent or marco rubio or
donald trump or ron desantis made a
comment like this was like collecting
their latino people but like tacos the
view and every other show for weeks
would be saying this is what they think
of you latino people they think of you
as tacos and burritos and chimichangas
and everything else but when it comes to
democrat do democrats doing these things
the entire media runs cover for them uh
here's whoopi goldberg
these two ladies and for these two
latinos in the front row are jessica
and they're just they're
they're just
i mean
bodega is what you meant to say you
think somebody might have read the
speech
beforehand and said maybe you don't want
to say it like this yeah but this is you
know i i i won't even say what i what it
is because it's you know we all step and
poo from time to time and so this
happens but this was really
you can hear the people going what's she
saying
and then that nervousness
see what's interesting about that is
whoopi knows that it's kind of messed up
what jill did there right she knows and
we're going to show you more in just a
second where she gets into it but for
her when it comes to the democrats
saying something they just stepped in
poo right do you think again if this was
a republican that said this if this was
josh hawley or mike lee that said oh he
just stepped in poo no it would be this
he has unmasked himself he obviously is
a racist and thinks of uh latino people
as tacos now of course the fact that
there are masked people in their
audience while they sit there on mass
that's a completely separate point uh
but okay whoopi she was like sort of
like kind of almost getting there and uh
well she continued speaking about anyone
don't you avoid food related yeah that
is tacos whether it's skin color well
you know
i would be upset if somebody said you
bring the chicken out in people right
you know i was i i don't i don't know
who who
yeah that's kind of what you know that
it was yeah and okay
this is what it was it was a racial
stereotype that she used racial
stereotype so i don't know who wrote
that for but and it was such an unforced
error right because if you think about
political affiliation um there is
republicans are making the argument that
there are more um
hispanics that are now registering as
republican and that i i don't know if
that's true um and i don't think it's
true
so remember when when uh democrats do it
they step in poo or it's an unforced
error would they be that gracious
uh if a republican did it i think not i
also want to comment on this thing that
whoopi said about chicken i love fried
chicken i really love fried chicken i
love watermelon these are good things
these are good things if you like the
things there's nothing racist about it
right like i love fried chicken i can't
i don't even know how you could
associate that with racism in any way i
have watermelon in in the fridge right
now you guys want some watermelon after
the show i don't associate that with
anyone's skin color when i went to whole
foods and bought a watermelon i bought
the watermelon i thumped the watermelon
i enjoy watermelon um so if you're
associating like specific foods with
specific people sure there's ethnic
things there's north south okay people
eat different things like this but if
you say to somebody oh you like fried
chicken and then if there's a racial
connotation to that
first off it just you have a racial
connotation just in and of itself is not
racist if you like the thing right if
you like the thing remember the episode
of seinfeld where uh jerry is dating
this woman he meets her on the phone and
her name is donna chang and he thinks
he's dating a chinese woman it turns out
she's just a white girl from long island
and elaine has to explain they're all
talking about is this racist is this
racist and it's and elaine's like you
know it's not racist if you like the
things everybody likes chinese food
we've all just racialized everything to
the point of complete stupidity but
speaking of complete stupidity here's
joe scarborough on msnbc having a
complete mental breakdown over a bunch
of assorted stuff can you look
oh at the head-to-head matchup with ron
desantis the great white hope the guy
that we hear every day oh yeah from the
right man florida man from the right oh
he's going to win drawn to santa he's
strong
ron desantis he really showed the press
oh he really he really showed the
teachers oh he's banning books now he's
really showing people who like the first
submit and we hear that new takeaways
here joe top of which is excellent
impersonation typing as a foxnews.com uh
correspondent there
i think that first of all i think there
is a sense we've talked about it during
the show there is a frustration among
some democrats toward this white house a
sense of eternal gratitude to joe biden
for defeating donald trump in 2020 but
thinking perhaps he's not the right guy
to now defeat trumpism and that maybe by
issues
more americans agree with who the
democrats are than where the republicans
are the crackpots in arizona that are
lining up that looks like they're going
to be nominated uh to run there they're
conspiracy theorists they're weirdos
they're freaks uh uh they're they're um
you know they are the most unelectable
uh and yet they've risen to the top in
each of these republican primaries i
know that mitch mcconnell has to be
pulling his hair out because this should
be easy republicans are making a lot
harder than it should be
well i hate to tell you
joe scarborough joe scarborough who's
taken every position on everything often
got everything wrong nobody knows what
you honestly believe about anything he's
referring there to blake masters my
friend who's been on the show
who is going to be the next senator from
arizona and he's also referring there to
carrie lake who's been on the show who's
going to be the next governor of arizona
and he's calling them unelectable and
mark my words people uh they're both
going to win and they're both going to
deservingly win
and the idea that they're freaks and
weirdos and and unelectable and
conspiracy theorists and all of these
things uh is completely insane blake his
platform is so freaking clean and clear
and crisp on top of the fact that he's a
good dude he's exactly what we need in
politics he's a young guy with a family
three kids he's a good father and a
decent man he was in the tech world for
years one of peter thiel's top guys he
did not need to go into politics but
he's going in because he wants to
protect his state and protect this
country he wants there to be a safe
border he wants law and order and a
whole bunch of other things his democrat
opponent by the way mark kelly uh he
wants to pack the supreme court um but
you know i get it joe scarborough is
just is just sort of a nut bag and msnbc
is a televised mental institution so why
are these people losing it though why
why are they losing it whether it comes
to gender
or abortion
or that everyone that's going to win is
unelectable
it's because they're losing americans
and they almost sort of got it right
there
on the view the clip that i showed you
previously where sonny was like oh and
it does look like latinos are uh voting
republican now as we know mayra flores
just crushed it in texas to be the next
congresswoman in a district that was a
hundred years of democrat control
they're losing everybody uh and partly
it's because nobody believes that joe
biden is a functional president right
now but don't tell that to joe biden
mr president what's your message to
democrats who don't want you to run
again
they want me to run two thirds say they
don't
read the polls jack you guys are all the
same that poll
showed that 92 percent of democrats of
iran would vote for me a majority of
democrats say they don't want you to run
again in 2024. 92 said if i did they'd
vote
i mean he completely made that up he
completely made that up we showed you a
cnn poll from yesterday cnn is not
thrilled to have to show you a poll
about a democrat president not doing
well that was it 96 percent guys was it
96 percent of democrats under the age of
30 do not want him to run
on top of the fact that just think about
you don't need polls on this just think
about in your life do you know anyone
that really wants joe biden to run again
do you know anyone that thinks joe
biden's doing a particularly good job
the only two people so far that publicly
i know want joe biden to run again are
pete k pete cause he wants to keep his
job and kamala because she wants to keep
her job but she's just lying all along
because she wants him out so she can
take over and then why does she want to
take over not because she thinks not
because she has a vision for the country
or is competent or anything else but the
people pulling her strings whoever those
people might be will be pretty thrilled
to have a sort of more mindless buffoon
than joe biden in so there's some
interesting things here because there's
such an incredible opportunity there
really is guys like all of this
craziness i know it feels crazy and all
the gender stuff and the race stuff and
the media stuff like it's a lot but what
it really also leads us to is that
there's huge opportunity here right it
really is the truth so how are
republicans
or conservatives or just relatively sane
people disaffected liberals how are they
going to save this thing uh well uh elon
musk and you know i often talk about
elon musk because of the twitter thing
but he's right in the center of things i
think in many ways not only because of
his pedigree and the work that he does
and starlink and tesla
and the boring company and all of that
stuff but because i think he represents
a certain shifting of things he
represents a sort of gen x guy who gets
technology who's not particularly
political but he's become political
someone who's mostly a liberal his whole
life but is now starting to move to say
a more i would say like a post-liberal
thing something like that uh so he had
an interesting tweet two days ago that i
want to read to you he was responding to
somebody else and he said trump would be
82 at the end of term which is too old
to be chief executive of anything let
alone the united states of america if
desantis runs against biden in 2024 then
desantis desantis will win easily he
doesn't even need to campaign now i put
out a little twitter thread uh
responding to elon that really caught
fire yesterday and i think it gets to
the heart of what's going on here and i
want to show it to you and and i would
love to hear your thoughts on this and i
know the locals community uh is talking
about it and it's blowing up sort of
across uh across platforms right now so
i quote tweeted him i said the problem
is that biden isn't running meaning
isn't running again he served his
purpose as for trump he has to decide
whether he wants to be king maker or go
for gold in a system which will never
allow him to have it either way elon is
paving the way for cowardly libs to vote
desantis which is good i continued in a
follow-up tweet elon musk said that he
felt trump was a bull in a china shop
and that's true but there is no metaphor
of a panther in a china shop who slyly
lets himself in and knocks off a few
selective items i made that point to
eric weinstein in 2017 and then there's
eric uh referring to my comment on that
and i think i've got one more tweet here
my hope is that trump and desantis will
work it out privately there is a huge
opportunity to fix the country right now
and there are very few voters who can
actually be swayed but the non-insane
libs bill maher barry weiss joe rogan
could probably move a lot of people to
desantis my guess is that the mar weiss
holly weird crowd will go down with the
damn ship but rogan must types will go
to desantis the latter is a way bigger
group of people regardless the question
still remains what does trump really
want so the reason i wanted to read this
to you because it's not it it sort of
caught fire online but i think i think
of getting to the heart of it and it's
it's why i end up talking about elon
musk so often bill maher so often the
ex-lib so often and all that because if
you think about the election this way or
you just think about america this way
the most people at this point the huge
swath of people have made their mind up
so let's say let's if we're to believe
that 81 million people voted for joe
biden and 75 million voted for trump and
let's not factor in a certain amount of
people die you get a certain amount of
new voters okay let's say those are
roughly what the numbers are right well
how many people that voted for trump out
of those 75 million are going to look at
what's happened in this country and be
like i'm either voting for biden who is
not going to run biden's obviously not
running and he may my guess is he
doesn't make it to the end of the four
years but how many of them are going to
be like i'm voting for biden or whatever
whoever's following up by it and be it
kamala harris or anyone else that they
throw in there gavin is i'm like boy the
policies of the democrats have really
been good over these years the high tax
stuff the locking us in our house stuff
the inflation stuff all these things by
the democrats have been good there's
almost no argument that anyone who voted
trump or is a conservative or republican
would be like oh that thing is better
now there is an argument obviously that
people who just had trump derangement
syndrome and just could not get there on
trump or had completely legitimate
reasons not to like trump or whatever it
might be
that they might go boy after four years
of biden and the dems and big government
and big taxes and lockdowns and coveted
that i'm just going to vote the other
way i actually i've started waking up a
little bit
and you know i care more about states
rights and i want lower taxes there's
definitely an argument that people could
move that way okay so
that's one piece of this but the other
piece of this is if you take those two
groups right and let's say the bulk of
those people aren't going to move who
who are the people that could move right
now well it's basically the non-woke
liberals that's why i reference those
people that's why i talk about the bill
mars and the rogans uh often because
it's the people who should at this point
fully get it those are the only people
and they're just representatives of
people right so they're just avatars in
this equation but it's it's you watching
this or it's your brother or cousin or
friends or co-workers
these these people who always thought
they were liberal their whole lives who
may be old-school liberals i wrote a
book about it who must now come around i
think that's the only voting block in
america right now that there's actual
fluidity to where they actually might
say hey i've had enough of the democrat
party and i'm going to move so that's
why i think it's so so uh
important to talk about because
those are the people that can move it if
you only go to the base all the time if
you only talk about the base then you're
not going to move a lot of people i
would say all that couched in it's why
the desantis thing makes sense all of
the people who had the trump derangement
stuff it's like well they didn't you
know it wasn't necessarily the policies
people remember that the the country was
in good shape the economy was doing well
and all of those things so it's like
desantis he's fought the machine he
fights the media it's all the stuff that
joe scarborough is making fun of him for
and the only reason joe scarborough is
making fun of him is because he knows
he's actually accomplishing things
but he has the policy we know he knows
how to staff properly
and he doesn't have all the baggage that
trump had but all of that being said
uh trump has to decide what he wants to
do and that really is the x factor in
this entire thing right that is the one
piece of this that's floating in the
ether that until trump officially says
he's going to do it or maybe trump's
going to wait to the midterm see that
the republicans are going to crush it
see that desantis obliterates the
opponents there are basically no
opponents here in florida and wins this
tremendously or hugely as he would say
and then he's like you know what i will
support the guy and i'll go out there
and i'll campaign for him and everything
else so that's kind of that's kind of
where we're at so again you could to
wrap this whole thing up it's like
liberals if you just look at it they
used to think that abortion was safe
legal and rare that was the same thing
and now it's basically pregnancy centers
equate to al qaeda so if you're a sane
liberal if you're a saint liberal where
are you going to go where are you going
to go well it's on you all right hang
tight for the cold close let me get to a
couple comments real quick uh comment oh
at 100 usa says bacteria on mars is life
but a heartbeat in the womb isn't yeah
it's one of those ones where it's just
like you can get them so easily on all
of this stuff right front page of every
newspaper tomorrow if we found some
little microscopic something somewhere
life
everything we know about science has
changed we're not alone
heartbeat eight month baby nothing it's
nothing
amy says modern feminists are erasing
women one pronoun at a time yeah they
the the modern feminist movement
is a complete grift and sham that has
nothing to do with protecting women or
girls absolutely and steel ray says
apparently someone did not read the
federalist uh the federalist papers
senator hirono yeah by the way i really
enjoyed reading those things it's like
isn't it refreshing to know those people
didn't know what they were thinking
about and those documents have lasted a
long time hirono you are just a footnote
in history because nobody is going to
remember you other than to clown you
but the idea that oh we can't imagine to
possibly ponder to know what those old
people used to think about stuff just
completely ridiculous uh guys reminder
tomorrow
we've got a regular show in the morning
but then tomorrow night i will be doing
a reuben report episode live at the
miami improv you can go to daverubin.com
slash events couple seats left christina
pusha ron desantis press secretary
you'll be joining me uh lisa booth from
fox news my buddy dave roboy uh patrick
bet david part one is up on rumble and
locals uh rumble and youtube right now
full things up over on locals and uh
that's all i got for you today and just
remember guys if if joe biden doesn't
make it
at least we've got kamala
elections matter when you win an
election
you get to set the rules how can you win
with russian interference though that's
what i'm scared about in 2020 but
rightly because i think he's an
illegitimate president that didn't
really win so how do you you know fight
against that in 2020 you are absolutely
right so
again as a member of the senate
intelligence committee i will tell you
that we should believe exactly what the
intelligence community has told us
which is russia did interfere in the
election of the president united states
in 2016.
you